so you did a great interview on HuffPost
live that I watched and you said that so
many people see the end result of films
the walking the red carpet all dressed
up and and it looks so wonderfully easy
what would you want people to know about
this project and all of the hard work
you're doing behind the scenes well I
mean I don't really think I think that
knowing for the general audience knowing
too much about the blood sweat and tears
go on behind the scenes would kind of
lesson the movie magic experience for
people but I think that there when the
criticism comes in about oh well you
just do that and you just so easy to do
that and you're so lucky because you
have that or bubble above there is so
much work and there's so much
disappointment and there's so much
insecurity and there's so much you know
fighting but fighting this good cause
and getting very like excited about it
and then going downhill because it
doesn't then you have your time you're
your own you know captain of your ship
and I mean making an independent movie
is very complicated thing at any time
but in this time especially and they say
oh well you know you can shoot it on 5d
and you can do this yeah sure I can do
all of these things and I will do all of
these things but I shouldn't just be you
know regulated to like wow an
independent film is a really you know
it's independent film means very little
money it means but very little money
often leads to much more creativity and
that's what I'm interested in I'm not
interested in the kind of a general
story I want to fight the good fight I
want it to get ugly and I want I think
people want that do you know but it's
not especially doing things uglier
especially doing things out of the
general realm of how you know that
people can't say oh well I saw that and
that must be like that so then I can
watch this and it's you know it's about
taking a chance and you know so it's a
lot of struggle and you know I if I had
the check to write out my own movie I
would absolutely do it you know a few
months ago not know but you know I'm an
independent filmmaker and I come from an
independent film family or we all you
know work really hard
to make the art and get to struggle and
you know sometimes you're broke and
sometimes you have money and you know
that's the way it goes but there's
nothing insecure about it you really
have to be kind of like strong and you
know it's a really strange life but also
it's such a rewarding life that you take
the good with a bat
you